as you can see your pattern is scored based on the number 10 so out of 10 is your mark as you
can see it's split up into two parts we have our accuracy and our presentation on this side so
we'll start off with the accuracy first so your accuracy is actually scored from a four so from
the number four you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern and then with that one
any mistakes that you make whether if it's a minor mistake you get a minus of a 0.1 if it's a major
mistake you get minus 0.3 so i'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two
minor mistake it's a very very small thing so say we're doing a outer block if it's not your
shoulder height maybe it's a little bit lower or maybe it's a tiny bit higher that's a minor
mistake so that's a 0.1 a major mistake would be you're supposed to do an outer block in the pattern
but you forget and you say you do a rich hand strike instead so that would be a major mistake
so with the minor mistake uh let's say pattern one for example there's about 20 steps
it's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns uh sorry the 20 steps
so the reason for that would mean uh it needs to be absolutely perfect to get uh
to not get a deduction of 0.1 so it's not uncommon to let's say there's 20 steps and you made let's
say 15 mistakes so what would that be so we'll leave that there uh on this side and we'll come
we'll just calculate the score at the uh at the end so a major mistake say you're supposed to turn
to the left but you turn to the right that would be a major mistake so obviously we do want to try
and avoid any of these major mistakes so uh after we've done our pattern that's when we move on to
the presentation side so the presentation as you can see it's from a score of six uh this
six is actually split up into three parts so we have one two three here so with this one
uh for a score of two is your power and speed your rhythm is also a score of two and your
expression of energy is also scored out of two as well so we'll start off with the power and
speed so with this one whether it's your blocks your kicks your strikes your punches anything
you are that you do you need to be nice and strong and it has to be fast as well so that
it's one thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch but it has to be both strong and
to get uh high in that in that category the next part is your rhythm so the rhythm uh when you do
start your pattern there is a rhythm to the pattern it's not just really fast all the way
through it's not slow all the way through there's a slow fast slow fast kind of aspect to it as well
so you do need to kind of work on your rhythm and that's also scored out of two
uh the last bit is your expression of energy so what is expression of energy so that's basically
how loud you shout so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well so i say you're doing
your pattern really well it's really fast and it's strong your rhythm is really great but you're not
shouting very loud or you can kind of tell the judges can kind of tell oh you're not really
uh confident uh you're a little bit nervous so that's what i'm willing to kind of improve on
on as well so i'll just come around to this side so with this one four color belts and black belts
a little bit differently so if you're a color belt you'll actually uh your average so where
where the judges actually mark you from it's actually from a 1.1 so this is your average so
say you did uh you did all right you did average compared to everyone else
your score for one two and three it'll start from a 1.1 so if you're less than average in
the judge's eyes you might go down to say for your power and speed you might get a
one or even a 0.9 if you did really great you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4 so each individual
uh category you need to obviously get as high as you can if you're a black belt generally depending
on the competition you will be scored from a 1.3 so 1.3 would be your average uh that you start
from so say your current speed uh was above average uh average you might get scored a one point say
let's say 1.3
point four for now uh say your rhythm was only about average uh it wasn't amazing it might be
just a 1.3 but let's say you didn't shout very loud so your expression of energy your average
was 1.3 it might drop to say let's say a 1.0 so with this one we'll come over uh down to this side
so with this one uh as i was saying it's a total of uh
10. so let's see before presentation we had 1.7
one two three so you had a 3.7 let's say you made the 15 mistakes so with this one obviously
don't be too discouraged if you do get uh pretty high in your mistakes uh this is with the judges
we have three judges usually at the panel and each judge obviously is very subjective so
from their point of view you might have made a lot of mistakes or you may
may have made not a lot of mistakes as well so that's why we have the three judges
and we average it out as well okay so uh say we did our uh 15 mistakes very small mistakes
so if they're all uh minus 0.1 it'd be 1.5 so you go 4.0 minus 1.5 which equals 2.5
so this would be your accuracy score so with our presentation like before we're saying we've got a
3.7 here so we add these numbers at the uh after the judges are finished scoring so you would get
for this pattern a 6.2 which is actually very good so i'll just talk about a little bit more
now about this number here so if you're a color belt uh if you're a yellow uh or above and you do
your patterns you're going to get a 6.2 so if you're a yellow uh or above and you do your patterns
it's not uncommon generally for a color belt uh the average is about a four to five so if you get
a number between uh four and five out of ten for your pattern that's actually uh generally considered
pretty good so anything above that uh you can consider yourself pretty good uh if you're a black
dog the average would say because um we're talking here about the higher presentation as an average
anything
from five to two sorry five to six is actually considered uh pretty pretty good and anything
over a seven is actually considered almost world class so if you get a seven for any of your
patterns you generally need to uh pat yourself on the back you did an amazing job so uh we just
went through our pulpe scoring so just remember accuracy is a 4.0 presentation is a 6.0
accuracy is judge during your pattern presentation is after and then we get
the two scores that we add up and we get that number so with this one obviously uh say i was
uh i was judge number one i would give you a 6.2 there was another judge on the other side maybe
he saw a couple more mistakes than i did and maybe this one would be a little bit lower it
might be a five point something another judge on the other side they scored a little bit higher
so we'd get the three numbers and then we'd average that as well so i hope this helped you
guys so make sure you enjoy your pulpe competition and anytime make sure obviously you record down
your numbers
okay so minor errors while you're watching this video i hope you enjoyed it and i'll see you in the next one bye bye
we cannot pause the video this time but you're going to re-watch your performance and then
major and then after the performance would be power and speed coordination of rhythm and
expression of energy and it will automatically be calculated at the end yeah so
we have the random code we're going to label it alpha and f to tell you that you can use any of the
code but it will be defined under your own parameters so if you don't find it in your own configurations
it's up to you yeah maybe not the same thing so we'll come back to that later but i don't want to
let them know that you know it's a problem and it will be erroneous for you if we don't do that
i think that's what's going to happen um so we're gonna go ahead and make that a little bit
different so we're gonna go in here we're gonna make a little bit more of an example but i'll
make it something like this and then i'll add some extra notes and i'll also add some more
notes to do it this way so if you don't find it gonna be a little bit less interesting so
if you don't find it gonna be something like this if we don't do it this way it's going to be
Thank you for watching.